hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo
[Música]
un residente conflicto en etiopía
atención a la ya inestable situación en
el cuerno de áfrica a principios de
noviembre del primer ministro de etiopía
viaje ganador del premio nobel de paz en
2019 le declaró la guerra al frente para
la liberación popular de la región de
tigre el partido que gobierna las zonas
considerado rebelde por la
administración de ahmed y fue señalado
de atacar dos bases militares los hechos
desencadenaron jornadas de
enfrentamientos y la declaración del
estado de emergencia por seis meses el
conflicto avanza con los civiles en
medio del fuego cruzado al menos 30.000
personas han huido de la violencia en
busca de refugio en la vecina sudan y
cientos siguen desplazándose la onu
alerta sobre una posible crisis
humanitaria a gran escala y pide un
corredor humanitario que permita la
salida de civiles un equipo de france 24
fue hasta la frontera entre etiopía y
sudán y habló con algunos de los
refugiados esta es la situación
este camión lleno de personas acabo de
llegar de etiopía lleva a 10 personas
que dejaron todo cuando el conflicto
empezó al otro lado de la frontera estos
hombres estaban en el campo cuando
escucharon el primer disparo y huyeron
pasamos tres días en la carretera ya van
seis u ocho días desde que dejé mi casa
y desde entonces he vivido afuera la
gente huye a donde puede no hay nadie en
los pueblos mira mi ropa no tengo nada
que comer ni tomar no me queda nada la
gente fue asesinada vemos cadáveres en
todas partes sin ser enterrados ellos
están armados monitoreando todo así que
no podemos enterrar a la gente estábamos
muy asustados por nuestras vidas así que
huimos de aragón a unos kilómetros más
adelante llegan a la primera población
sudanesa muchas casas están vacías aquí
y algunas familias pudieron encontrar
refugio sin embargo miles no tienen
techo y la ayuda no ha llegado aún mira
esta casa no hay nada adentro y mira
estos niños no han comido en al menos
cinco días como los vamos a alimentar
nosotros subimos para salvar a nuestros
niños vinimos aquí han pasado cinco días
llegamos a pie desde el pueblo my cadera
el ejército de sudán nos trajo
y desde la frontera gracias a dios nos
trajeron aquí pero dónde está la comida
dónde podemos tomar agua los niños se
están muriendo la agencia de refugiados
de las naciones unidas indicó que
trasladaría a estas familias etíopes a
una nueva locación que tendría que ser
construida al menos 11.000 personas ya
están allí y los refugiados siguen
llegando una bióloga estamos registrando
un promedio de 400 a 500 personas que
llegan cada 12 horas hoy desde las 5 de
la mañana hasta la una de la tarde hemos
reportado 500 refugiados en el gobierno
de sudán distribuyó comida y ropa pero
no fue suficiente los comerciantes
venden los elementos de necesidades
básicas a los migrantes sin embargo sólo
unos pocos pueden comprarlos y siguen
esperando la ayuda internacional para
poder sobrevivir
la zona en conflicto es de difícil
acceso y también las regiones hacia
donde emigran los que huyen del
conflicto en sudán el centro de tránsito
de anda jr en capacidad para recibir a
300 personas está desbordado pues son
miles los que buscan protección varias
organizaciones no gubernamentales se
despliegan en el área para ofrecer
ayudas france24 visitó la zona
5 y 30 de la mañana estos refugiados
etíopes se despiertan luego de superar
una pesada noche en el suelo y sin un
refugio para protegerse algunos esperan
un autobús de la onu que los traslade a
un nuevo campamento y dejará atrás la
ciudad dejando en sí
nos encontramos en el desierto la noche
ha sido fría solamente esperamos del
gobierno alimentos y refugio estas cosas
son básicas y fundamentales para las
personas saltarín
alrededor del mediodía llega un nuevo
grupo de refugiados la zona es de
difícil acceso por lo que las ong se
están estableciendo lentamente mientras
se alistan para ayudar a los refugiados
una organización se encargó de la
construcción de baños para miles de
personas desde su llegada a los
refugiados han usado el monte como baño
pero representan muchos riesgos las
heces ingresan al suelo y se mezclan con
el agua potable lo cual causa problemas
de salud para refugiados y comunidades
locales y saludable desde el inicio del
conflicto diversas ong sudanesas
trabajan en la recolección de fondos
provenientes de la población local
a estas comunidades contribuyeron para
la alimentación de refugiados y los
solicitantes de asilo luego vinieron las
organizaciones y se hicieron cargo como
el programa mundial de alimentos y la
ayuda musulmana
a las cinco y treinta de la tarde se
sirve alimento para cientos de personas
que esto les ayudará a aguantar hasta
que sean trasladados a un campamento
permanente durante las noches la
temperatura vuelve a descender el
gobierno sudanés espera que al menos
200.000 etíopes puedan cruzar la
frontera en las próximas semanas debido
al conflicto además de los etíopes que
se desplazan a sudan preocupa la
situación de al menos 96 mil refugiados
eritreos que residen en campamentos de
tigre y que dependen de asistencia
humanitaria causada por el conflicto y
el dato de inmigración de la semana
unicef alerta de la situación de los
menores en medio del conflicto de tigre
el fondo de naciones unidas para la
infancia calcula que unos 12.000 niños
algunos sin padres ni familiares están
en centros de registro en ciudadana
unicef pide asistencia humanitaria de
urgencia para los menores desplazados
hasta aquí inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
siga con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]